مكان في مصر ما حدش يعرف عنه فين درجه
مئويه طالعه من بطن الارض ميه سخنه ما
بتقدرش تلمسها
[موسيقى]
ما احنا رايحين طريق شرم الشيخ بيبقى فيه
في الطريق منطقه كده ليها داخله يعني ممكن
ناس ما تلاحظهاش خالص هو ممكن تلاحظها من
الدخان اللي طالع داخله كده عاديه جدا
بتقوم داخل بالعربيه بتاعنا وبتلاقيه اسخن
عيون موجوده ما تقدرش تحط ايدك فيها كتير
لان هي بتغلي اول ما بتطلع من المصدر ما
اقدرش احط ايدي فيها اكتر من كم ثانيه بس
قدام شويه بعد ما تخش كده عامله بركه
طبيعيه محاطه بالشجر وعامله زي حمام
زاكوزي تنزل فيها ميه هتستحملها بص المنظر
بعيد عن خيالي اكنك قاعد في حمام سباحه
طبيعي وناس بتنزل فيها مثلا 20 دقيقه لنص
ساعه لان معروف ان الميه دي علاجيه ميه
الكبريت بتعالج المفاصل مع الحاجات دي
فبتنزل فيها فتره كعلاج يعني
حلوه قوي
اعتقد ان هو الجزء ده من الفيديو هو اللي
خلى الفيديو اصلا ينتشر جامد لان الناس
كانت مستغربه قوي من الدخان والمنظر خصوصا
المنطقه دي كمان فيها عيون موسى جنب
المكان ده على طول اوضح ان المنطقه من
زمان بتطلع ميه بتطلع حاجات من الارض في
الباطن في حاجات يعني الفيديو انتشر فده
دليل كبير قوي الناس انبهرت فاعتقد كانت
حاجه مبهره بالنسبه لهم